Hello, everyone.
All right.
I have shared the screen and there might be some more people popping on here,
but we will get started.
Have a handful of questions that came in.
Hope everybody had a good weekend.
And all right, we'll get started here.
So, okay, is there a rife program for inner your viruses?
So, there are many programs for viruses.
So, you know, not knowing which specific virus you have,
you'll just have to try a number of different programs.
So, any viral program that is available to run on the rife machine
would be a good program to try.
It doesn't matter where the virus is in the body.
When you're running a rife program for viruses,
it will, you know, it will work throughout the entire body.
So, last week on the Monday's Zoom call,
I showed a little screenshot of the rife software, you know,
where you go in and you pick your program.
There is a little search bar.
So, if you look, it's either to the right or to the left of your screen,
depending on what kind of computer you have,
but there is a way to search for different rife programs
that might be helpful for you.
So, look for that little search bar.
You have to click on, there's little tabs.
There's one that says name.
So, you have to have that one highlighted.
Then you can type in whatever you're searching
for you are curious about.
So, I would type in virus and then you hit the search button
and it will bring up any program that would be particular
for viruses or any program that has virus in the title.
So, viral complex is a good one to run.
There's Epstein Bar Virus Programs that help with a number of people.
A lot of people have Epstein Bar Virus.
So, that would be a good run to run and any of the viral programs.
So, absolutely, you can try running many different virus programs
and see if that helps you with your symptoms.
I'm not sure what kind of symptoms you're having,
but any virus program, there might be virus foot baths as well.
So, you can look in the IAM Pro Wave folder
and look for some of the programs.
There's a really good Epstein Bar Virus Foot bath program
that people have gotten a lot of benefit from.
So, that might be one to try as well.
So, just experiment with different programs,
whether it's using it from the bulb or the foot bath.
And hopefully, you will get some benefit for that.
Right.
When a thermogram is performed on a person working with Connors Clinic
and the results are shared with a clinic,
do these result augment case specific plans
for causation findings and therefore,
a potential change to the treatment
and recommendations at the Connors Clinic for that person.
So, yes, we have used thermography as a tool to help.
And when we had patients coming in the clinic,
we did a thermography scan on everyone.
We still do some thermography,
so local patients can come in and get a thermography,
but thermography, you can find a local thermographer
and get a scan.
And just like everything else, thermography is a tool.
So, we don't put all of our eggs in one tool basket
or tool bucket.
We have to look at a number of different tools
to really get a full assessment of what's going on.
So, we do use thermography,
and if you get a scan elsewhere,
you can send us the results.
We do prefer that you use a metatherm clinic
and if you're wanting to find a metatherm clinic,
you can shoot me an email and I can send you the link
to find a metatherm clinic.
That's the specific camera that is used.
It's the only one I believe that's FDA approved.
And so, that's the one that we use
and that's the one that we recommend.
And so, if you go elsewhere,
try to use a metatherm clinic,
and then you can send us the results
and we can have that on file.
We can take a look at that if we think
anything needs to be addressed.
We can help you navigate that.
But, thermography does not diagnose anything.
Thermography is showing patterns of heat.
And so, heat can be generated
from a number of different things.
Yes, it can be generated from active cancer cells.
It also can be generated from inflammation.
Can be generated from infection
or a muscle tear or injury or healing from surgery.
So, there's a number of different things
within the body that can generate heat.
Of course, now these scans are being interpreted
by medical doctors.
And so, they are obviously trained to look
at the patterns of heat and figure out what is normal,
what is abnormal, what it might be correlated with.
So, we get a full report.
And then we can use that as a tool to help us.
We can use it to track progress.
Thermography is better for some things
and not so great for other things.
It's not gonna give us a good glimpse
at how prostate cancer is doing.
But it is very good for breast cancers.
And again, it can't diagnose or tell you,
oh, you're getting much worse
or oh, you're getting much better.
But we can look at trends.
And we can correlate that with everything else
that you're doing.
And we can kind of use that as a tool.
Oh, okay, maybe we see some more heat.
So, maybe we want to try some additional things.
Maybe everything is looking much better.
There's less heat.
So, okay, that's good.
Let's stick to the current protocol.
Things are moving in the right direction.
The other thing,
thermography is good for is looking at dental health.
So, dental inflammation can be a root cause
of many different types of illnesses.
Breast cancer in particular can have a root cause
of a dental factor, your lymphatic system
from your dental, from the perioral cavity drains down
into the chest and into the clavicle.
And so there's a lot of correlation between dental issues
and the meridians and lymphatic drainage
and all of those things in particular breast cancer.
So, yes, we use thermography.
Again, we don't put all of our eggs
in the thermography basket.
So, certainly if you would like to do that, you can.
And it's typical to do an initial thermography scan.
And for breast tissue,
then you would need to go back three months later
and get a follow up breast scan.
That's just standard.
That's called establishing your baseline.
So, they're really trying to figure out
what's normal for you as an individual.
And two scans are more accurate than one scan
when it comes to breast tissue.
Just because breast tissue is so sensitive
and can change.
So, they may recommend that.
So, don't be alarmed if they are asking you
to come back in three months.
That's standard to establish baseline.
Then once we have your baseline,
then it can be an annual scan
or more often every three months, every six months.
So, depending on what the recommendation is,
but absolutely we use it as a tool to help us
just gather more data to figure out what's going on
and to look at trends and patterns
with follow up thermography scans.
So, we can use that as a tool.
Is there a reason thermogram is not a general
or is it a specific case-by-case recommendation,
a service of the Conner's Clinic?
In our case, we do not see this as being recommended.
So, right, we maybe didn't specifically recommend it
for use as a tool.
It is in the binder and the resources section
under beneficial therapies.
So, it is something that is noted in the binder
as a tool that people certainly can use.
Of course, now that people are all over the place,
not just local to us,
I guess thermography isn't a recommendation
that we make to everyone because we're not physically able
to see people in the clinic
and do a thermography scan on everyone.
But, absolutely, it can be done.
There's no risk in a thermography.
There's no radiation exposure.
There's no tissue compressions,
so there's no negative to it.
But, again, it's not something that, you know,
a thermography scan, you know,
it's not something that we are basing
all of our decisions off of, but it can be a tool.
Our studies led us to this form of evaluation
to address the body systems as a whole
and an effort for causational findings and remediation.
So, yes, absolutely.
Kudos to you.
You're doing a lot of research, you know,
looking into things and other ways that to help the body.
So, absolutely, you can use it as a tool
but it's not the only tool we look at.
So, we've got to look at everything else
to kind of get, you know, the best picture
for every individual and make decisions from there.
We use nebulized hydrogen peroxide
with WooGauls to fight viruses.
Would it be safe for my dad who has his thyroid removed
and takes synthetic thyroid medication?
So, of course, I can't, you know,
I can't really give a recommendation
for somebody who is not our patient
and, you know, kind of tools
that we don't necessarily utilize at the clinic.
I have absolutely heard of people
using nebulized hydrogen peroxide
and certainly in kind of the wake of the pandemic
and everything, the WooGauls solution
where iodine has been used to fight viruses in particular.
So, while I don't know off the top of my head,
any, I don't know any downside for somebody
who specifically has their thyroid removed
and is taking synthetic thyroid medication.
I can't think of any contraindication,
but again, I can't make a recommendation for, yes,
that's totally safe and use that.
I can't say that, but I don't know.
I just can't think of any negative off the top of my head,
you know, certainly with everything you don't want
to be using too much of it.
You want to be, you know, maybe a couple of times a week
or if, you know, you are experiencing symptoms
on the onset of symptoms to kind of fight the virus
from really kind of taking hold.
People have used this as a tool.
So hopefully that helps a little bit.
What is the address to male energy swap?
So I've got the address listed here.
Dr. Kevin Conner's 2261 State Road 35.
Somerset Wisconsin 550 or excuse me, 54025.
And we do have forwarding addresses
from our old clinic in Legelmo
and if somebody has our other Somerset
the therapy clinic address that they've sent it to.
So those two addresses will forward to this address here.
However, of course, it might take a little bit longer
for things to get to us.
But this is the preferred address
where we get the cheek swabs.
Hello, am I able to get a copy of the findings
from my cheek swab?
I'm interested in knowing the specifics of the findings.
My binder lists my cause as toxicity.
Is there more specific information available?
Also does that mean toxicity is the driver
or are there other things?
Okay, we'll pause there for a second.
So we don't have any more specific reports
or anything to provide you based on the findings
from the cheek swabs.
So the only thing that we have is what you have in your binder
is in the testing result section of the binder.
There's the pages about understanding our testing
and then we've got a summary of the testing.
And so what we're doing in our testing is we're trying
to test to determine cause,
then we're trying to test to determine
specific cancer-fighting supplements for every individual
and then we're testing diet to see what we believe
the cancer is using as a fuel source.
And so we know what we want to eliminate from the diet.
So we're not sending this in to lab core
and getting an official readout of these results.
We're using kinesiology and it's energy testing.
So Dr. Connors is doing energy testing to determine
what could be balancing these weaknesses
and energy to get the body energetically
to work to the best of its ability
so that it can then fight the cancer
and anything else that's going on.
So there's no official readout.
This is our testing and what you have received
is our report, you know, in quotes,
I guess you would say is our report,
the Connors Clinic report of the testing results.
And again, it is the cause.
And yes, toxicity comes up a lot of times as causes.
A toxin is something that is, you know,
a chemical or a heavy metal, an herbicide or a pesticide.
So something that is not living that is a toxicity
for the body, sometimes a biotoxin comes up.
A biotoxin is something living.
So a bacteria mold fungus parasites
is something that is living that is causing harm to the body.
Sometimes hormones come up as a cause.
These are things that need balancing
and could be the reason why
because of this imbalance within the body,
it led to a condition within the body
where cancer could take hold and develop.
So know that we all, all of us,
have something that could cause cancer circulating body
at, you know, all times,
anytime, multiple times throughout every day.
And the body has systems in place
where we can keep this imbalance
and never get a diagnosis of cancer.
So when somebody actually does develop a cancer diagnosis,
it's because these systems, you know,
have gone amuck for whatever reason.
So, you know, in the case of a toxin.
So your body has ways to deal with toxins, you know,
if it's a toxin that we've ingested from our food,
the whole digestive system is designed
so that your body does not absorb the toxin
into the bloodstream and we're eliminating that toxin
through waste, you know, through either urine
or the bubbles, you know, through our breath.
So eliminating the toxin so it's not entering the body.
So something has gone wrong within the body.
We have a leaky gut scenario.
We've got, you know, we're under stress
so our immune system is suppressed
and we can't get this toxin or it just takes hold,
it gets into the blood, it gets into the cell,
that toxin can cause damage to DNA,
which can then turn into, you know,
faulty replication cycle of these cells
where it goes haywire and then we have this rapid replication.
Well, then we have another system in place
that can, you know, keep that under balance.
So if we have this rapid replication,
then we have tumor suppressor genes
that are supposed to come in and figure out
what's going on there.
Okay, this isn't normal, this is not supposed to happen.
So let's figure out what's going on and fix it
and if we cannot fix it, we need to stimulate death
of the cell because this is not good, we don't want this.
So that's kind of the process.
So something happens, something gets in the cell,
could be a toxin, could be a biotoxin
for some reason your body has a,
is in this state where the checks and balances are not there
and something has gotten into the cell
cause this malfunctioning in the replication cycle
and then the immune system comes in, you know,
to try to take care of it
and our tumor suppressor genes kick in.
So if your immune system is down,
whether you're sick, whether you're stressed,
whether it's lack of sleep, you know, emotions,
you know, all of these things play a role
and when these are out of balance,
that is when cancer can develop
and it then takes years for you actually
to get that diagnosis of cancer.
So when we're working to determine cause,
it is what energetically is gone wrong
or do we need to address in the body
to help get the system back on track
so we can give things functioning
to the best of their ability.
So kind of a long-winded answer
but hopefully that kind of gives you
a little better insight as to how we're kind of working
with this and so we're working to address the body as a whole
and the cause is a piece of what could have gone wrong
within the body for this to develop
and we need to address that.
So we're looking for these root causes
and then the cancer fighting supplements,
the cancer balancers are things that are testing for you
specifically as an individual for your cancer
to help fight the cancer, the current cancer
that you've got going on.
So it could look absolutely and it does look absolutely different
for everyone even if somebody has the exact same diagnosis,
they might have different supplements
for their cancer balancers because again,
everybody is different and everybody has a different cause
or a different internal environment
that has allowed this to happen within the body.
So it doesn't necessarily mean that the toxicity is a driver,
it's a reason why this might have developed in the first place.
My diet recommendations include meat.
Does this mean that animal protein isn't a driver for you?
Yes, so if we have not eliminated meat,
then you can safely assume that protein is not a driver for you.
And yes, so she goes on to say so many others
are swearing by the raw food diet or no meat
or drinking gallons of juice, so a lot of juicing.
So those are general.
Again, everybody is different and every cancer is different
even if the diagnosis is the same.
So we're taking an individual approach
to really try to seek out what is best for every individual.
And so if we have allowed meat on your diet,
then that does mean that your cancer
is likely not driven by amino acids.
So you can have some needs and maybe it's driven by dairy
or maybe it's sugar.
So what is listed in that lab or excuse me,
testing results page, the very bottom is the driver.
So whatever is coming up as a driver
is what we want you to mainly avoid.
And then when you get into the nitty gritty
of the dietary recommendations,
we do go into more detail with the yeses and noes.
So there might be some things
that we still want you to stay away from
even though it didn't come up as your driver
because we just know it's not good
for the whole environment of the body.
And so maybe gluten didn't come up as a driver
but we still want you to avoid gluten.
Maybe dairy didn't come up as a driver
but we've still marked dairy, no.
So but you can, if meat is allowed,
then amino acids have not come up as a driver for your cancer.
Now sometimes things change
which is why we always encourage follow-up testing.
Cancer is sneaky and we have to stay ahead of the game here.
Sometimes things can change.
So when we're doing those follow-up cheek swabs,
we may change your diet.
We may need to try something different.
And so that will come up.
We look at that when we do the follow-up cheek swabs
and if we need to adjust the diet, we will.
And yeah, sometimes people do great
on a diet of juicing, raw juicing.
But that doesn't mean that's good for everyone.
Somebody who's cancer is driven more by sugar.
There's a lot of sugars in juice.
They're from the juice.
There's a lot of nutrients and enzymes
and things that flood the cells immediately
with these nutrients from juicing, which is all great.
But it is higher in carbs and not good for somebody
whose cancer might be driven from those sugars.
So I apologize for not asking during the binder review.
Please don't apologize.
Absolutely fine.
I know questions come up at different points for everyone
and sometimes listening to these calls
will obviously trigger more questions.
And so never apologize for not asking something
during the binder review.
Obviously she's referring to some of these binder questions.
But absolutely fine to ask binder kind of related questions
on any of the Q&A Zoom calls.
We certainly encourage you to utilize the binder review
so we can kind of get some of those initial questions
get you understanding your protocol, understanding the binder,
what we're asking you to do, the supplements, the diet,
all of these things.
So good to do that initial binder review
to get those initial questions asked.
But absolutely, sometimes things come up
relating to food and diet and certainly
fine to ask these questions on the Monday
or Wednesday Q&A calls.
So it's exactly what these calls are for.
So don't apologize for that.
My tumor marker was my 15.3 marker was 75.
And it went to 143.
And my CEA tumor marker was 2.5 and went to 4.2.
What else can we do?
Or what else do I need to do frustrating?
Yes, so it can be very, very frustrating.
And I know Dr. Connors has talked a lot about lab results
and how we need to make sure we're kind of assessing
all different aspects.
And again, not throwing all of our eggs
into the one tool basket of tumor markers.
So how are you feeling otherwise?
Are you doing any other scans or imaging or labs
when how are those numbers looking?
I know this person in particular is doing
some conventional care along with our care.
She has gone through a couple different viral things
in pneumonia.
So she's just had a lot going on.
And I would just say keep doing everything that you're doing.
You certainly can run the RIF programs more frequently.
If you're home during the day, I don't know if you're running
them during the day or not.
I know you're doing everything that we're asking you to do.
But you certainly can, if you're home during the day,
run the programs during the day, even if you're not really
sitting in one spot, if it's just in the room,
if you're in the kitchen and you're making a meal or doing dishes
or just doing work in the kitchen, you can have it on for an hour
or so in the kitchen, even if it's not right next to you.
And it's just on the counter if you're working on the computer
and it's in the office, it doesn't have to be right next to you.
It can just be, it doesn't have to be on you.
It can be right next to you.
Even if you're just getting short an hour here and hour there,
you can do more rifing.
I know sometimes these labs can fluctuate
based on what you're doing.
I don't know specifically with these, the CA 15.3 or the CEA,
with the conventional therapies that you're doing
in our therapies, I don't know if these numbers can be skewed
because of die-off.
So I'm not quite sure with that.
You might want to check in with a doctor who's
running these labs and see what they say.
I don't know if they would change any of their protocols
with what they're doing.
I know everything that you're doing with us
and with conventional, it's kind of new.
You haven't been doing it for a very long time.
So however often they are testing tumor markers,
I would say maybe in another month.
Just see, keep doing what you're doing.
You can do more coffee enemas.
You know, if you're not doing sonas,
you can do some sonas.
Try to work on, you know, we see these numbers
and we just, we go into this panic mode
and I know it's so easy for that, you know,
that switch to be flipped, but try to work on emotions
and keeping fear down, keeping anxiety down
because it just really creates an environment
where it's harder for the body to heal.
So whatever you need to do, you know,
make some plans with some friends,
listen to uplifting music, you know,
sometimes just doing all of these cancer therapies
is just, ah, you need a break.
And so if you need a break, then absolutely take a break.
You know, go visit, you know, again,
friends or family, you're going a little,
you know, excursion to, you know, the next town over
and you know, go up for a drive and look at the fall leaves.
So try to get your mind off of it,
try to reduce stress, just keep working the protocol.
I don't know if the conventional doctor has any other things
or suggestions, but we'll see in fall of labs what the trend is.
So we kind of have to work on trends
and not focus on one singular lab marker or one test
because definitely there's things that can skew things.
So we will just be in touch and follow up closely.
Maybe it has to do with, you know,
the illnesses that you're recovering from,
you know, all of these other things.
So we'll keep close tabs on it.
Certainly can do another follow up, cheek swab.
I can't remember when the last one we did
for this person in particular, but I think it was pretty
recently.
So I would say it in a month, you know,
do another to a marker test and we can be in touch
if we want to do another cheek swab.
Okay.
For the past week, each morning, I feel fine,
but an hour after consuming the connoors,
shake with all my powders and AM supplements,
some about 30 plus kachava, I feel tired
and lightly nauseous for the rest of the day.
Yesterday, I didn't take any powders or supplements
and felt really good.
Today, I feel very good
and I've only taken the connoors supplements.
Next, I'll do the powders and work in the rest
of the supplements throughout the day.
Hopefully this will help any other suggestions.
So keep doing what you're doing, just play with things
and this happens a lot.
We have a lot of conversations about, okay, I don't feel good.
I think the supplement is affecting me.
I just, do I need to try to push through it or, you know,
really just not makes me feel not so great.
So we don't want you to feel horrible
and sometimes people have some sensitivities to things
and maybe we can find an alternative.
So supplements one at a time.
If you're not feeling well, back off of supplements
and it's okay to stop supplements for a day or two,
see how you feel, start them back up again.
Start them one at a time.
See if you can identify if there is a singular supplement
that is the one, that is the culprit,
the one that makes you not feel bad.
So try to assess that.
Sometimes we can pulse supplements.
I know there's a number of patients who are pulsing things.
So they don't have to take so many every single day
but they are still getting them in just on a rotational basis.
So we can kind of help you with that.
If that is something that you want to do
or you can just divide up your supplements
into two or three different categories.
And then for a week, take the ones from the first category
and then after that week, put them to the side
and take the second group, the third group.
So you're still getting them in.
It's just not all of them daily and see if that helps
and maybe before you do the pulsing,
you kind of do some of these other experiments
like you're doing to see if you can really identify,
maybe if I take a little bit less,
maybe if I take it in a different way,
maybe if I do the powders or the supplements first
and powders later, maybe if you take it with food,
if you haven't been taking it with food,
maybe if you try it without food.
So it's a little bit of an experiment
and I wish I had hard set rules
or something to tell you that would magically make it,
you feel better, but unfortunately, I don't.
So you have to just experiment a little bit
and don't feel bad or guilty if you have to take a day off
like you did and then you felt good
and just keep experimenting like that.
All right, my upper or my mid-upper back hurts frequently
any recommendations to reduce this tension.
So I don't know currently what you're doing.
I'm assuming that you are taking a lot of anti-natural
anti-inflammatory, some curcumin,
so a lot of the natural things to help with pain.
Certainly I can revisit your supplements
and see if there's anything else I could recommend.
Clear and flam is something that we use a lot
to reduce inflammation, can be helpful with pain,
but also just trying to figure out,
okay, what is this pain from?
You know, are you adjusting your body?
You know, I know your tumor is large and on your neck
and maybe it's preferred pain from the tumor itself.
You're holding your body differently.
There's pressure on your neck and your spine.
So just trying to kind of do different things
to relieve that pressure.
You know, I don't know how you're sleeping.
Maybe it's the position that you're sleeping in
and you need some different pillows or, you know,
try something that way, a tens unit.
I don't know if you have a tens unit,
but a lot of times that can be helpful for pain
and we do have that available on our store.
It's again called a tens T and S unit
and it just kind of gives some electrical stimulation
to the muscles you can put.
There's little pads that you can stick on
in different locations so you can treat
many different parts of the body.
So for you in the mid-over pack,
you know, I'd be kind of putting the pads there
and you can do, you know, different lengths of time
with this stim stimulation, the tens unit.
And that can provide a lot of relief from pain.
So that might be something to look into, yeah,
and then just making sure you're on the natural
anti-inflammatory is running the rife programs
for pain, running the rife programs for inflammation.
You know, you can run back programs, you know,
for back pain and things like that.
So again, just kind of trying to experiment
with different things to see if there's something
that can help.
And then coffee animals, you know,
can be great for pain as well.
They stimulate the parasympathetic nervous system.
So if that can really help alleviate some pain
and you can do multiple coffee animals in a day.
All right, so essential oils,
I have been putting frankincense with carrier,
with a carrier oil on Prometheus daily.
So again, if you've not heard this person refers
to their tumour as Prometheus, so has a name.
We gotta get Prometheus.
And so he's putting essential oils on Prometheus daily.
I have been reading that frankincense clary sage,
mer lemon grass, citrus oils, lavender,
thyme, peppermint, and spearmint all work
to help fight cancer cells.
Can we rotate these or do one type weekly?
Yes, absolutely.
You can do either or you can rotate on a daily
basis, you can do multiple of them,
many of them daily.
So whatever works for you, you can diffuse them,
you can use them topically.
Yes, try with a carrier oil.
So you're not, you know, having pain,
some oils can be a little hot, you know, peppermint.
So if you're using it and there's an open sore
or anything it might create some pain,
it shouldn't last, but with a carrier oil
that can help and I would absolutely try those.
Those can be great and diffuse them.
And is it okay to take these orally or only topically?
I know you can take some essential oils orally
and I guess it depends on the brand that you're using.
So I would just be really careful about the brand
and the sourcing because a lot of times
sourcing isn't great and it might be, you know,
if it's not really high quality,
it could be cut with some other oils or things
that maybe wouldn't want to ingest.
We use young living essential oils
and they have their vitality line is,
it's the same essential oils.
So for example, frankincense, the regular frankincense
and then they have the vitality frankincense.
It's the exact same oil.
It just has a different label.
So the vitality line has the white label,
which means you can take it orally.
It's just, you know, they for regulatory reasons
have to separate out the label.
So the vitality lines are the ones that you can take orally.
So the ones that you've mentioned here,
I don't know of any issues with taking it orally.
I think they are all fine to take orally,
but again, I would just be careful
with the brand that you're using
and make sure you're trusting your source.
And I would, you know, if you're gonna try some
orally, just try a little bit and try one at a time
so you know how your body reacts and go from there.
We have an herb garden.
Could I add the time and sage herbs to my diet
or make sage and time tea in your thoughts?
Absolutely.
Any herbs that you grow in your garden
are wonderful to add to your diet.
They have many healing and health benefit,
beneficial properties.
So absolutely you can add those to your diet.
You can add herbs to smoothies.
You can cook with them, make a tea as you've suggested.
That would be absolutely fine.
Okay, we've got, that takes us through all of the questions
that came in.
I'm just remembering that I had a question
from somebody on my email that I was going to put on here
but I forgot until just now.
It was a question about a collagen supplement
and if they could take that.
And I did look at that collagen supplement.
It was a marine collagen.
And it looked like a good product.
So yes, you can take that collagen
and hopefully it can help with some of the bruising
and skin irritation
and those sensations that you've been getting.
So you can take that and see if that helps.
Okay, some of the chat questions here.
Okay, can my rife cause me to be up all night
and feel bad?
Was up until 5 a.m. turned off right,
right at 3.30 a.m., as I felt I couldn't sleep
with it any more than night.
Most nights have been good.
So yes, sometimes the rife and different programs
can cause a different reaction within your body.
So it might be good for you
and really for anyone who's just starting off with the rife
to really just keep a note pad by your nightstand
or wherever you have your rife machine
and just keep a log of how you feel.
Because every program is a little bit different
and Wednesday night might keep you up.
Maybe there's loud or frequencies.
So the noise might be disturbing your sleeper,
distracting your sleep.
The light itself might be brighter
and might be causing you to be up.
And again, there are different frequencies in each night.
And so you're getting those.
Each night, the frequencies will kind of repeat themselves.
But each night of the week is a little different.
So there might be something in, you know,
the Sunday night program that is a little different
that might be triggering a different response.
Or it could be a cumulative effect.
You know, this person has not had the rife machine for very long.
And so maybe it's, oh my gosh,
I've done this for four nights now.
And, you know, your body is just, you know,
at a point where we might need to do a little more detoxing
or, you know, you might be getting some of these initial reactions
that could be related to detoxing.
So it can be normal, but we want to just monitor that.
So sometimes if we just move the rife ball
a little farther away from the body,
the therapy is not as intense.
So you can try that.
So maybe, you know, the next time you run the Sunday night program,
okay, I didn't feel so great last Monday,
I'm going to not have the ball so close to me.
So you can try moving the ball a little farther away.
Maybe you feel fine.
So maybe, you know, then you slowly kind of work the ball a little closer to you.
And as your body kind of gets used to everything.
Oh, now I'm able to do the Sunday night program with a ball right next to me.
So the closer the ball is to your physical body,
the more intense the therapy is.
We want the ball to be as close to the body as close to the cancer site as possible.
But of course, we don't want you to not be feeling well or not getting sleep.
So move in a little farther away.
If you have to turn it off, that's fine.
Just make a note of, of, you know, each night's program and see how you feel.
Make sure you're staying hydrated.
You could do some extra coffee enemas, some extra detoxing.
Do a foot bath, one of the detoxing foot bath programs.
To just kind of offset some of these things that you're feeling and experiencing.
Let's see. Okay.
When do you recommend a follow up?
Yeah.
So typically every three months, you know, and that is flexible.
So if you're doing really well, you don't have to do it every three months.
If you're kind of in maintenance mode, everything is good.
You know, you can check in every six months.
Or we have some people who check in every year and just to make sure.
If you're not doing well or if you're having some symptoms that come up,
then absolutely you can send us a cheek swab sooner than that three months.
So the three month mark is just kind of the typical to just kind of check in.
Make sure everything is still on on pace, but we can do it sooner.
If we need to if things are going on or or we can stretch that out if you're doing really well.
All right.
Also, I was told to stop my B crop complex after the swab.
What would be the reason for this?
So many B vitamins are methylated.
So if you're B complex and that's, you know, a great, you know, most B vitamins,
if they're quality, you know, are methylcobalamin.
So it could be a really wonderful, great high quality B complex supplement.
But for our cancer patients, we do not want them to be taking methylated versions of vitamins.
And that is because methyl groups they attach to different sections of DNA and they turn sections off.
And this is very important because we we need that to happen for our, you know, our DNA in order for the instructions to be appropriate for that particular cell type.
So a heart cell needs to know how to act like a heart cell.
And so the methylation patterns of that particular cell are methylated so that it can act like a heart cell, which is different than the liver cell.
So methylation is important, but methylation will turn sections of DNA off.
And in the case of cancer, when we're taking supplements that are methylated, we are providing a an abundance of these methyl groups.
And so there is the potential for these methyl groups to turn off tumor suppressor genes.
So we don't want to do that. So we take you off methylated versions of B vitamins.
It's not that the B vitamins are bad for you. It's just the version we want them to be in a version that is not going to potentially turn off tumor suppressor genes.
So we look at that and we will make a recommendation if we, if we want you to supplement with a different version.
So B12 is is likely methyl cabalamin. So we would switch you switch you to a pro hydroxyl cabalamin or an adenosyl cabalamin.
So versions that are not methylated.
And then folate, we don't want you to be taking methyl folate. So we prefer that you're getting your folate through your food and your diet.
And then also that greens first supplement that we most likely have you on. We have most of our patients on the greens first supplement.
So that is a whole food source multivitamin. It's what we use is our multivitamin.
And so you're getting B natural whole food farms of B vitamins from that.
And that's how we prefer you to get your vitamins. When we look at genetics, we might say, ooh, you really need more B12 or you really need more B vitamins based on your genetic pathways.
So possibly he didn't make a recommendation for you to switch it out to a different version because you're taking the greens.
And then when we look at your genetics, we can assess if we really need you to be taking extra or maybe you don't need to.
So we can reassess that. But hopefully that helps. And that's the reason why we take people off their B vitamins or the other reason would be if it's just not a good form, not a good supplement in general and it's using synthetic versions of B vitamins.
Folic acid is the synthetic version of folate. And that should not be taken by anyone.
So nobody should be taking folic acid because folic acid.
Well, it's similar in structure to the active farm of folate, which is folate. And that's the preferred form in food.
But because they're chemically similar, the folic acid, which is not active yet in folic acid needs to become folate in order to the bind to bind to the receptor sites and produce the desired result, desired response within the cell.
Folic acid is not active yet. It's synthetic. But because it is chemically very similar, it can bind to the receptor sites on your cells and actually block. So if it binds to the receptor site, it's not active. So it's not not able to produce that result.
Excuse me. And so then it's actually taking up that receptor site space and is blocking the natural folate from getting to that receptor site.
So that could be another reason. Maybe it was folic acid. Maybe it was a methylated version of the B vitamins.
I've never had pain in my pancreas before. Since I started the rife, I do get pain there now. Is this common? Sometimes we can have some pain in different organs. And when we're using the rife machine, we are stimulating an immune response.
And so there can be, you know, people can feel it in some organs, you know, breast cancer patients oftentimes will not, you know, sometimes I guess, yeah, those experience some pain when they're using the rife machine or they may have some twinges or little zingers when they're using the right machine. So we are trying to produce a response within the body.
We're activating the immune system to go attack those cancer cells. So we're using the frequencies of the cancer cells specifically based on your type of cancer.
And we are alerting the immune system to go in and attack those specific cells. So there can be an inflammatory response at those sites.
And so it can produce a little bit of pain. Dr. Conner says a wonderful blog post about good pain versus bad pain. And in this case with just starting the rife machine and experiencing some of these sensations with the rife machine.
That is not bad pain that is pain because we've introduced this therapy and it's producing a response within the body. And so that we actually look at that as a good thing, you know, of course, pain is uncomfortable.
And if it gets out of control or if it continues, let us know and we can, you know, do some further investigating but some pain with the introduction of the rife machine is not not necessarily bad.
Okay, is agave syrup? Okay.
So agave syrup while it is natural, a natural sweetener. The way it is processed within the body is a little bit different. It actually can be worse than, you know, fructose.
And so typically I would say, you know, stay away from agave, you know, a little bit here and there might be fine just just like anything, you know, a little bit here and there would be fine.
But if you're using it on a regular basis, I would maybe switch to a stevia or a monk fruit or maple syrup.
So something else that is still natural, but doesn't affect you or deliver detoxification process, quite like agave.
So agave can do, you know, actually higher on the glycine index than fructose. So I would switch.
I was reading and a cancer support group that vitamin A supplementation wasn't okay for cancer patients, but I don't remember the reason any thoughts.
I'd like to order the immunopack as recommended, but I am hesitant because of the vitamin A.
I'm trying to think vitamin A and contraindication with cancer and I can't think of any.
We use vitamin A and we believe it to be very important for a cancer patient because vitamin A is very important for cellular differentiation.
So it helps abnormal cells to become more normal.
And so we use vitamin A and we think it is important for cancer patients, along with vitamin D.
Vitamin D combined to apoptosis receptor sites on cancer cells and stimulate death of those cells.
So, you know, high amounts of vitamin A, maybe can be toxic to the liver, but, you know, normal amounts of vitamin A.
That would be really high, like acutane, you know, the prescription that they give for, for acne patients with cystic acne, that's a really high dose of retinoic acid, which is, you know, vitamin A.
And blood work needs to be monitored when people are on that prescription because it can be toxic to the liver.
High vitamin A, you know, we don't want anything in that extreme amount, but normal doses of vitamin A can be very helpful for cancer patient.
And our vitamin A is combined with the vitamin D. So it's in the supplement, the ADK complete or it might, people might be taking ADK eval.
So those are all of the fat soluble vitamins in one supplement. And there's a lot of studies out there that show there's synergistic benefits when you're taking all of the fat soluble vitamins in one.
And then taking it with food too because it's fat soluble. So I wouldn't worry about the vitamin A in the immunopack.
I don't know if that person in that, that support group was talking about really high amounts of vitamin A, I'm not sure.
Um, ran around is the brand. Okay, yes, I have heard. So that is this person is referring to the essential oil brand that he is using.
And that one is a good brand. I believe that is, is made by a company, a local company here in, um, in Minnesota.
And that is a good brand. So yes, I would trust that brand.
It was said that in a supplement form, vitamin A could promote cancer. Oh, yeah, I'm not, um, I'm not sure.
I have not heard that, um, maybe you could send me though, oh, it was, I don't know if there's a link to anything that they were referring to, but yeah, but we, I have not heard that specifically about vitamin A and just normal doses.
You're very welcome. Thank you for jumping on the call. It's been an hour, so we'll wrap it up here. Thank you so much for your questions. Let me know if you need, um, any more information based off of anything that we talked about today.
Otherwise, keep checking in on the membership site and take a look at the courses that Dr Conners has put together.
Um, all right. I don't see any other chats coming in. I think we covered everything. So you guys have a wonderful rest of your day.
You are very welcome and have a great week as well. Take care everyone.